dude i was thinking they should have
more animals right
how many animals do they have 70 animals
like that's sometimes my that's one of
my issues with god is
bruh bake another batch daddy
you know you got all the capabilities
you got
you know i'd love to see like kind of a
unicorn that has
uh wi-fi in its horn
that's got that [ __ ] hard hitter on
the top that router
wouldn't that be great you can't get
wi-fi but suddenly
one of these unicorns shows up
and dude think about a unicorn that's
another thing you don't notice how much
magic is in it that's another type of
corn
if dude imagine the first unicorn walks
up
you know somebody shot that [ __ ] down
bro you know what i'm saying
i mean in no offense man but somebody
really
popped that cat down boy if you saw a
unicorn show up you were like damn
boy i mean there's no way you couldn't
think
this horse is trying to [ __ ] boy
this horse is trying to in my butt
you know this horse is into the dark
arts there's no way you couldn't think
that
but it's interesting how much magic is
in the unicorn
they're probably top six magic animals
i think anyway if you had to think about
it um
i don't even know what we're talking
about uh but yeah imagine that first
unicorn rolls up do you sit in there
with your buddy
maybe you guys are having a couple
garbanzo beans or
you know trying to get rid of yellow
fever or whatever i don't know i don't
even know what year it was when they
showed up
and next thing you know this bad [ __ ]
rolls up with that
with that freaking that top piece
baby a unicorn's basically like a shark
it's like the shark of horses and
but they got magic in them you never
know how much magic is in a unicorn by
looking at it
you just think damn this horse is really
honestly probably
trying to meet some local men
you know we're trying to do or trying to
pick a lock or something
or what else are trying to just you know
push a button on an elevator
or what else i don't even know what a
horse would do with that horn on its
head
you know hang out just maybe hang
laundry but like just one shirt
but you don't realize when you see that
unicorn how much
how much power is in them and how much
magic full of magic
you just don't know man people don't
know they don't know the magic that we
might have inside of ourselves
they really really don't know good
evening good afternoon and
other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes your life
well you could watch this one or watch
this one watch this one watch this one
watch this one ah